for the first time in 50 years
Campbell's iconic soup can looked
different in 2021 even though the
changes are subtle it makes the can feel
like one that feels at home in your
pantry versus one that you remember
seeing in grandmas or granddad's Pantry
good so let's break down Campbell's
first major Rebrand in decades and how
those small changes are breathing new
life into soup the company's core
product the redesign is so slight that
customers might not have even noticed it
it was really important here that
Campbell's did this evolutionary change
didn't step away from their iconic look
and feel this is Rob Meyerson the
founder of brand strategy firm heirloom
he's been studying Campbell's redesign
for a new edition of the book designing
brand identity though Campbell's Soup
company makes more than just soup its
namesake product has been on shelves for
130 years the label has been tweaked
many times since then but only
significantly redesigned a handful of
times like in 1898 when the company
first chose the colors that would define
it the red and white on the can which is
inspired by the Cornell football team's
uniforms that red and white wasn't
touched in the new redesign but other
elements were tweaked for example the
new logo gets rid of the drop shadow and
disconnects the letters drop Shadows are
a little bit of a relic of an era and
design where adding Dimension was seen
as a positive removing any unnecessary
components like that subtle drop shadow
just puts all the more focus on the
recognizable assets the overall effect
is a simpler more modern take on the
logo and modernizing is a theme
throughout the redesign The Medallion
they they retained all of the text and
basically the same imagery within The
Medallion but they added some Dimension
to it that looks a little bit more 3D it
pops a little bit more it feels brighter
on the cans the word soup has has been
written in a different color they've
gone from a serif type face which has
these little feet and pieces on the
bottom of the Pea for example and
they've gone to what's called Sans serif
without a serif and that's typically a
little bit more modern they also
retained this slant on the interior of
the O and so I think this is just
striking a balance between modernizing
refreshing but keeping some
recognizability between the old can and
the new can the company did add
something new a picture of each soup's
ingredients they wanted to emphasize the
food ingredients in the can Aaron back
is a Wall Street Journal columnist who
covers all things Campos this is about
reaching young people who care about
food quality who care about what they're
feeding their kids and saying look
there's real tomatoes in this and
there's another benefit to those
pictures instead of using a picture of a
bowl of soup or a spoon holding soup
they've gone with just this simple shot
of the ingredients the piece of chicken
and the noodles and that alone makes
them stand out from everybody else in
the space
so why did the company go through all
this trouble for redesign so subtle the
last thing you want to do is make it so
that people don't recognize your your
cans or your products and that
Campbell's can was already so
recognizable and had been for decades it
was memorialized by Andy Warhol and in
catchy ads Campbell's tomato soup good
for a long time Campbell's iconic status
translated into very strong sales around
the turn of this Century that came to an
end and they started running into
problems soup sales began a steady
decline for years the overwhelming
perception among young consumers is that
Campbell's soups were old-fashioned
unhealthy out of style and unappealing
changing that was part of CEO Mark
Clause's new strategy to prioritize
soups after years of expanding Beyond it
some of that expansion worked Campbell's
snack division now accounts for nearly
half of the company's sales but Fresh
Foods like baby carrots and salsa were
less successful the company ultimately
sold its entire refrigerated food unit
in 2019. the Insight of the new
management was look the name of the
company is Campbell Soup company it's
our most important product so the
company tried to appeal to younger
consumers by refreshing both the label
and the recipes they took out high
fructose corn syrup from the condensed
soup line the cream of mushroom cream of
chicken soups now have more Fresh Cream
in them the company also tried new
marketing like sponsoring an episode of
Top Chef I'm gonna do a Swiss chard
gratan making an nft and partnering with
the Madden NFL game
so far it's helped soup sales have grown
in recent years that's in part due to
the pandemic when more people were
cooking at home
but those lockdown customers stuck
around Campbell you know not too long
ago was viewed as one of the most
troubled of the major food brands but
last year as one of the top performers
stock went up 31 percent and that was in
an overall down year for the stock
market still the future of growth for
Campbell's isn't just in soup it's
snacks the company designates that
division's role as accelerated growth
but it was important for Campbells to
staunch its core products bleeding once
you clean up the product and also make
the label look more appealing what you
do is you kind of give a permission
structure that's something you can maybe
even be excited about to have a can of
Campbell's tomato soup in your pantry
[Music]